what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so getting back into x-men red I
want to cut a sidetrack here for a
second and the reason why is because I
was looking through the comments for the
first x-men red video and there were
some of you guys who were still a little
bit confused about the nature of
Cassandra Nova and that makes sense
because really unless you read Grant
Morrison's new x-men she's pretty
obscure so the way this works is
Cassandra Nova originally appeared in E
is for extinction which was the first
three issues 1:14 through 117 of Grant
Morrison's run her origin wasn't fully
explained that had come until new x-men
umber 125 but she had taken the son of
all of our Trask who had access to these
wild sentinels these signals that were
initially experiments and nothing was
ever really done with him but because
they were based on voice recognition the
son of all of our Trask or grandson or
some like that nephew I can't River was
the only one who was able to access them
and so she basically took him to that
location using to access the sentinels
and then killed him and then when that
happened she sent those sentinels to
Genosha which was kind of like a mutant
Haven and the massacred 16 million of
them and that explains why Genosha has
really been like abandoned and destroyed
ever since of course this is a story
that was written back in 2001 following
that questions reigned as to what the
origin of Cassandra Nova was what her
intention was all that kind of good
stuff and so fast forward to uncanny
x-men 1:20 I'm sorry new x-men 125 and
you end up finding out she's what's
called a mama doc now the way this works
is is it was Grant Morrison kind of
using basically metaphorical
storytelling because he does which is
dumb and what he essentially said is
that inside every person is like their
evil counterpart do we have like a good
and evil to ourselves a yin and a yang
that when every single human being is
you know comes into existence which is
to say like in the early stages of their
development as we develop there will be
an evil counterpart to ourselves and the
kind of person we turn out to be is
based on whether or not we can defeat
that evil version of ourselves as it was
basically like RAM Morrison talking
about like the inner struggle of people
you know the good versus the bad and
that kind of thing that led into the the
birth of Cassandra Nova who's basically
like Xavier evil counterpart and
ultimately Xavier ended up like
defeating the essence of Cassandra Nova
but Nova herself didn't really have a
physical form she was more of like an
ideology and so because of that she copy
the Xavier R copy the DNA of Xavier and
gave herself a physical form which is
where she began to gestate in the womb
of Sharon Xavier the mother of Charles
when that happened Xavier kind of
quote-unquote sensed her presence
destroyed her and then she was kind of
this disembodied form that sort of went
out there and then eventually reformed
and then came you know showed up as like
a villain in the name all the universe
but again is tied into the grip the
nature of Grant Morrison's storytelling
which largely never makes sense to
anyone but Grant Morrison himself it's
kind of a weird thing but that's the
nature of her think of her as like an
evil few multi-male version of Xavier
with all the powers of Xavier that's
really kind of how she functions but
again her showing up here you know kind
of feed back into the first video her
showing up here is for the purpose of
just kind of like seating chaos and war
and hatred and really it's not something
she's creating it's something that's
already there is that it was only ever a
matter of time before something like
this happened and so again there's some
character building that goes on here
explicitly with a character of gentle
now again gentles character he's being
really created by by Tom Taylor and he's
very Incredible Hulk
esque and that's one of the things
that's important here is with regards to
and this is someone want to address here
for a second too because I saw this
question people didn't fully understand
what like x-men black was with regards
to what's going on right now in Marvel
Comics that though at the time as videos
being made marvel's kind of rebuilding
the x-men right like Secret Wars 2015
happens we go into the aftermath we get
all-new all-different marvel and marvel
tries to push the Inhumans like anybody
cares and no one does and and and they
kind of make the x-men take a backseat
by just riding you know having stories
that are written that are okay but don't
really like shine the x-men in the best
light and what this does is it led to a
lot of people hating the Inhumans even
more because they suck and you should
hate them and and getting angry about
the fact that like the x-men aren't you
know are popular and so in the aftermath
of that Marvel said okay fine let's give
people what they want because you know
we're a publishing house we exist to
sell books on why you would do anything
other than that but let's get people
what they want let's let's basically
start reforming the x-men and and making
them into the team that everybody knows
and this comes in several different
forms phoenix resurrection the return of
jean grey that goes into x-men red but
it also sees the launch of x-men black
and x-men black is basically just saying
like hey here's care here's stories like
one-shot stories based on characters
that you know to kind of give you an
idea of who they are so for people who
are longtime x-men fans is a return to
familiarity for people who are new to
x-men is giving us the stories about the
courage that we know and the way they're
supposed to be written so that's it's
really kind of like setting things to
rights is really the purpose that serves
but for gentle he's basically the
Incredible Hulk
he has the ability to like charge up his
power and become like almost infinitely
strong the issue with this is that for
reasons that were never originally
explained he basically had these kind of
mental blocks and he would experience
physical pain and this is explained here
when we end up learning like his mother
was very abusive that every time his
powers would
the best she would tear him down she
would physically attack him different
things like that and so a psychological
and mental blocks in place and what this
means this is kind of Tom Taylor's way
of saying his cap its strength level is
not anything that's limited it's not an
actual limitation instead is a
limitation he put in place so is these
little things that kind of go into
building these characters up and so from
here picks up with the x-men launching
an attempt to basically hijack a plane
over international waters and steal from
a dead person that's basically what it
is here now remember all of this stems
from from ambassador Mayer barber you
know who had basically been killed by
Cassandra Nova but the way it had been
recorded is it looked like Jean Grey had
killed her and so what Jean Grey intends
to do is basically like take the phone
take the phone to belong to ambassador
Marbury and then draw the audio off of
it and then broadcast out audio to the
world and show people how the
conversation truly happened but again
you know using trinary her ability
that's happened to machinery they
basically take the giant signal they fly
over to the plane and then of course
they turn around and enter it now this
is one thing to bear in mind with all
these little send you know sentinel
nanites that are in the in the brains of
almost the entire world's population
Cassandra Nova's tapping into it at the
same time and so what she's basically
doing is is essentially like making
people aware of where the x-men are and
then because of the nanites they're in
turn turning on the x-men and attacking
them so there's really like no safe
haven now while all that's happening
Jean Grey is also kind of speaking
directly with Cassandra Nova and this is
an important thing because what
Cassandra Nova says is you can try this
all you want to you can try to speak
truth to to all this hatred and fear but
no one's gonna care because in times of
fear and desperation people will believe
what they want to believe and people are
afraid of the x-men in this day and age
people choose the facts they want they
come up with with an opinion that come
up with what they believe to be right
and then search for information to
verify the fact that they're right they
don't look at all the information and
then come to a conclusion they come to a
conclusion and then search for
information to verify it and so because
that's the way people are you're not
gonna be able to change their minds
you're not gonna be able to like talk
reason into them because they don't want
to hear reason they want to hear
verification of their own beliefs and so
it's actually pretty smart of Cassandra
know to pick that up because it's 100%
and absolutely true the other half of
this is that where Jean Grey is kind of
analyzed the mind of Cassandra Noble
while she's talking to her Cassandra
doesn't care and the reason why is
cassano know is basically invoking KITT
abomination now Jamie Carlson was
originally introduced in superior Iron
Man and he was never really like a big
deal
the idea behind Jamie Carlson was that
he was like
five years old his mom like he was sick
one day his mom took him to work there
was a gamma experiment that had gone
wrong and basically he was blasted with
gamma radiation eight years later when
he was 13 his powers manifested he kind
of freaked out and ultimately like there
was an explosion in the house that
killed his mom and that was it he's
basically like an angsty teenage kid who
has the powers of a love abomination I
mean power is almost on the same level
as abomination he's not as strong as
Emil Blonsky but he's he's still strong
in his own right the idea behind this
though was that because he was kind of
free-floating for a while no one ever
really knew what to do with him but the
reason why kid abomination is here
though is because he is so powerful and
so because of that when teen abomination
is sent in he literally just starts like
attacking Atlantis worthy worthy x-men
or residing which sort of leads to like
gentle it's kind of a moment for gentle
scare Jory faces off against kit
abomination he's really the only one
that can go toe-to-toe with him with
physical strength but the x-men are also
kind of playing a humanitarian role here
because if they keep on fighting then
eventually kid abomination will just
drown because he's just kind of in a
mindless animalistic state now while
that's also going on the other x-men who
were on this plane literally like a fire
fight breaks out on the plane and the
action bring it into it pretty fast
because I mean you know you're talking
about like depressurizing and you know a
jetliner at 30,000 feet bring the whole
thing crashing down to the ground and
kill everybody on board but the x-men
basically stop it pretty quickly the
issue with this is that trinary loses
our connection to the Sentinel and when
that happens of course you know crashes
down on the plane and of course they
wreck you tres Q things pretty fast I
mean there's not a whole lot doing here
the phone is of course basically
captured but that leaves Jean Grey too
to kind of being unable to clear her
name directly no it's so instead what
she ends up doing is is like addressing
the world now in reality this is
actually kind of a good idea because
what it does is it just leaves things up
to how people will respond to it like
when Jean Grey makes his broadcast and
sends it out she basically says like you
guys are being manipulated by a being
named Cassandra Nova and when this
happens it's not the x-men taking a kind
of holier-than-thou attitude right like
you guys are stupid and so you've been
manipulated and so we are going to fight
on your behalf that's not really what
Jean Grey saying and it's smart to say
that because she approaches it more from
like a diplomatic stance we understand
what's going on here we'll fight on your
behalf even if you don't want us to
because there's a greater threat here
than what you're facing then then what
you recognize now again Cassandra Nova
doesn't really care it doesn't really
matter to her that much she's just kind
of going with it and just saying yeah
that's not my biggest concern at the
same time that happens Jean Grey
basically hones in on the location of
Cassandra which is in Genosha and it's
kind of ironic Cassandra would take up
residence in the places she destroyed
but then this leads to like a full
on assault by the x-men so literally
storm comes in bringing like a 300 foot
tall ocean wave and brings it in just
like crashing down on Genosha proper and
then at the same time like trinary tries
to like tap into all these little these
little nanites now here's the thing what
you're talking about here is is trinary
trying to perform the equivalent of a
telepath tapping into all the minds of
the world at once it can be done
but only by the most powerful of beings
you know trinary doesn't have the power
to pull it off it would tear her brain
apart and so Jean Grey's response it
actually comes from Gabi you know it
comes from
x-23 little sister twin essentially and
the question is asked why don't you just
use cerebro and it's such a smart move
because what Jean Grae does is she says
okay so like we need a vector here we
need someone whose mind can handle this
and we need someone who can count who
can basically control these devices at
the or shut all these devices down and
so what they do is it's a brilliant
maneuver what Jean Grey does is she
serves as a bridge do you have Gabi who
sits down at the at cerebro and puts a
helmet on and then you have Jean Grey
who touches both of them and what this
does is it allows a power of trinary you
know the abilities happen to machinery
to transfer through Jean Grey to Gabby
who in turn can shut all these machines
down because Gabby can handle it I mean
like her brain constantly heals itself
so it's not like she will be over it so
it should be overwhelmed and she'll be
shut down when Cassandra Nova realizes
what's going on that like all these
little nanite devices are being shut
down
then she Sims in a cheap [ __ ] be
citizen like her secret weapon which
turns out to be Rachel summers now this
is a very very big deal but let's
sidetrack here for a second so
explanation needs to happen here so most
all of you guys have have heard of the
story of Days of Future past
so in Marvel Comics across the
multiverse Jean Grey and Cyclops every
child they have has been a male it's
basically been like Nate gray Rachel
summers is the only female child of Jean
Grey and Cyclops in the Age of Future
Passed reality Rachel Summers was one of
the many people who was interned than
these concentration camps that were
created by the signals you know humans
and mutants when they were all taken
over you know when the signals took over
North America when they became
autonomous and conquered everything she
was one of many people who were interred
there now the way the original story
played out is you end up having Rachel
gray who sent the mind of Kitty Pryde
into the end of the past to stop Days of
Future past from happening the problem
is that because Days of Future past was
the future of the main Marvel Universe
when the events that caused that reality
stopped the Days of Future past became
an alternate universe and so for Rachel
summers nothing changed and she didn't
understand why and so she ended up
jumping
back to the modern day in a story called
Days of Future present basically skipped
from her reality into the main Marvel
Universe and she'd been here ever since
but how she stands now she's painfully
depowered in comparison to how she used
to be but her facing off against Jean is
a pretty significant thing because this
is a battle of some of the most powerful
telepaths in existence and so what goes
on here is that you have Rachel summers
who's totally dominated by Cassandra
Nova you've got Jean Grey facing off
against her own daughter and the fights
pretty severe so ultimately because this
would lead to Rachel's death where
Cassandra says fine you know if Rachel's
fighting back against me and she won't
kill you then I'll just kill her instead
Jean Grae stops Cassandra and hands
herself over and says fine take me
instead
like she spare my daughter and this is
kind of a cool thing because in reality
gene and Rachel didn't initially get
along when they first met you know it
was kind of a weird situation because
Rachel summers popped up after Jean Grey
had died and then returned some bonding
took place as time went on but it is the
daughter of Jean even if from a
different reality and so this is like a
parent fighting for the survival of
their child and so it's a pretty cool
moment here you know when Rachel's freed
in turn this isn't you know leads to
rachel kind of freaking out you know
when attacking Cassandra so on and so
forth and where Cassandra goes to kill
her Jean Grae says no stop Rachel leave
like like get out of here you know go be
safe do whatever you want to do and in
response Cassandra Nova kills Jean Grey
and that's exactly we would expect it
makes the most sense if Jean Grey is
like the only real formidable telepath
who could stand against Cassandra Nova
because like Emma Frost couldn't do it
so if like Jean Grey is the only real
you know formal telepath who could stand
against Cassandra Nova and literally
lets her guard down then why not destroy
her now in truth it's kind of a
MacGuffin because we end up finding out
Jean Grey was never there in the first
place and it's kind of cool to see it's
kind of a cool moment you know to have
this happen but it probably could have
been handled a little bit better her to
be honest with you guys and so using
cerebro to essentially like trick
Cassandra Nova the idea is like we're
all coming for you and so from here
suddenly things switch up and this shows
how intelligent Cassandra Nova is on the
island of Genosha
what is up happening here is this
broadcast is sent out to the world with
Jean Grey basically saying like I
withdraw my invitation to unite with
humanity I withdraw my invitation to
help you guys we are basically creating
a safe haven on Genosha any of you guys
who come here we will kill you we will
wipe out the entirety of humanity if we
need you it's suddenly like this really
dark militaristic stance and the reason
why is because this is not Jean Grey
this is
actually a artificial intelligence
message that's basically a duplicate of
gene grade that was created by Cassandra
Nova and that is genius because again
Cassandra Nova knows if people are
walking this nice edge if the average
human is walking a knife's edge and then
on one side is absolute fear and on the
other side is hope they will fall to the
side of fear they always have when it
comes to mutants as it was Cassandra
Nova knowing that she pulls it off is
actually a pretty smart move and so in
response to this Jean Grey does the only
thing she can do when she's given a
prompt by Gabby the idea is if we're
facing off against a telepath of such
incredible power Jean Grey does not have
the ability to shield the minds of the
world and even if she did you're talking
about robotic implants in people's minds
so there's really no way to overcome it
I mean a lot of them have kind of been
different kind of been destroy those are
the ones that are free-floating out
there and so in turn then the question
becomes how do you take them out like
how do you destroy a telepath of such a
high level of power keeping humanity out
of the picture keeping humanity from
acting is is a big thing because here's
the way the situation would play out
what would happen here is Jean Grey and
the x-men would lead an attack on
Genosha against Cassandra Nova but
Cassandra Nova wouldn't make this look
like the x-men like like there's
basically a war mutants breaking out and
if there was a war of like a basically a
mutants civil war that happened on the
planet it could destroy the world and so
humanity would respawn and humanity
would either jump so the civil program
or they would nuke Genosha and kill
everyone there and so because of that
but this could lead to the potential
annihilation of the entirety of the
mutant population not only that Jean
Grey also knows if they launch a full-on
strike because of how powerful his
Sandra Nova is that she would basically
take over the minds of everyone and so
in in that in that moment she kind of
says okay
then let's make a phone call and she
contacts Tony Stark now this is kind of
cool because with the x-men this is one
of the things to bear in mind is it's
kind of one of those returns the two
familiar with the x-men when it came to
the x-men population the mutant
population in Marvel Comics and the
x-men teams it was largely like we deal
with things in house like we don't
really reach out to the Avengers to help
us deal with things we keep it all
in-house we don't really deal with like
other people out there now a lot of that
was because of like the house that Chris
Claremont built and the fact that the
way the x-men were done back him is it
was usually focused almost explicitly on
the x-men themselves with very little
crossover among other teams and so
because that when Jean Grey reaches out
to Tony Stark she basically says like we
need your help on something and Tony
Stark says well I had to dump a ton of
money into pulling this off into
building these things but I think I can
help you guys out with this and so when
Jean shows up to Genosha they show up
prepared for about
and it's a pretty cool moment here
because what she says is we were
prepared for the fact that you would use
your telepathic powers against us and as
powerful as I am if I'm fighting I can't
protect everyone at the same time and
I'm the only real telepath here who can
go toe-to-toe against you and so what
she ends up doing there she basically
pulls out a helmet of magneto which is
freakin amazing she's like I never agree
with anything magneto did the guy was
too Mel to really think I was too
extreme but the one great idea he had is
that he had a helmet there would locked
telepathic invasion and then you find
out that the x-men had magneto helmets
and then you find out the name with a
submariner and all the Atlanteans had
magneto helmets and then the Avengers
show up and all the Avengers had magneto
helmets it's awesome like this is what
Tony Stark built magneto helmets for
everyone and it is badass so literally
that's a literally Jean Grey it's just
like this is war
it is the x-men the Avengers in the
Atlanteans facing off against really the
most dangerous mutant threat the x-men
have faced in quite some time it's
pretty awesome but without being said
guys we're gonna breed this video to an
end if you are new here two comments
explained make sure you guys to the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and yeah I will catch you all
later peace